they have a proverb here in China wear
new shoes but follow old paths so the
skyscrapers overlook ancient rituals
thousand year old temples nestled by
shopping malls and mega power status is
actually considered a return to the
country's rightful place after centuries
in the wilderness but now excitement
about the economic miracle is turning to
fear so should we be worried and what
happens next we've spent the past week
traversing the country we found a land
of contradictions where many people are
worried since the alarm bells of last
month this is Shanghai the country's
financial epicenter of course it was
here that China's Black Monday happened
a massive fall in share prices that
transmitted contagion and concern all
around the world all the same on the
surface this place seems to be booming
it's home to half the world's top ten
skyscrapers the Shanghai Tower finished
only this month is the continents
tallest changjun's unfinished ping'an
financial center comes a close second
but the building works are a reminder of
a more warring trend debt China's
construction bubble fed a housing bubble
which filled a stock market bubble the
question is whether all three threatened
to take down the economy entirely and
put the country 7% growth targets at
risk if President Xi is able to pull off
average growth rates of three to four
percent during his 10 years in office he
will have accomplished something that we
should really be astonished because he's
inherited a much more difficult economy
than we think there's a huge amount of
debt there's a huge amount of
unrecognized bad debt and there is a
financial system structured around a
very unbalanced type of relationship
with external volatility and it's going
to be very costly to adjust if you can
get your head above the hustle and
bustle of Beijing city like what you
tend to see are cranes construction
sites nothing the image of the economic
story here over the course of the past
few years but in order to get to being a
developed economy
me what you need more of in China is
consumption people spending money again
there's a difference between the surface
the smart shops in Chengdu and the
reality Beijing seems reluctant to
encourage more consumer spending
maybe it's because when households spend
and earn more they tend to want more
democracy and that is China's real
dilemma it's getting to the stage where
it may only be able to sustain its
growth by changing its political system
for the leaders in Beijing that is an
unappetizing prospect if anything
president G is actually clamping down
more than his predecessors especially in
Xinjiang province whether Muslim
minority resents Beijing's control in
Hong Kong this time last year a change
of stance on direct elections spot
protests that went off for months for
many China watchers it's all part of one
big story they say either the communist
leaders embrace democracy willingly or
they watch their economy slump and maybe
lose control altogether ed Conway's Sky
News in China